Ryanair es una de las empresas más innovadoras
del mundo y, a la vez, una de las más odiadas.
Todos hemos oído hablar de TESLA o del HIPERLOOP.
Pero… necesitaremos esperar unos cuantos
años para ver en qué medida esas empresas
cambiarán nuestra vida.
Ryanair ya ha supuesto una auténtica revolución.
Y no sólo en Europa sino en todo el mundo.
Sin embargo, es difícil encontrar a alguien
que no profese un odio visceral hacia Ryanair.
Esto se debe, en parte, a los esfuerzos de
su CEO, Michael O´Leary. Pocas personas han
trabajado tan duro para ganarse la animadversión
de propios y extraños con declaraciones como esta:
“Necesitamos que haya menos gente yendo
a los baños de los aviones ¿Cómo lo evitaremos?
¡Les cobraremos por ello!”
O esta otra…
Nadie quiere sentarse al lado de un gordo
cabrón. Francamente, nos ha sorprendido ver
la cantidad de pasajeros que no sólo quieren
poner un impuesto especial a los gordos pero
incluso quieren torturarles. –Michael O´Leary
Pero hay una razón aún más importante por
la que tanta gente odia a Ryanair. Os doy
un ejemplo. Si lleváis tiempo suscritos a
VisualPolitik, ya sabéis que yo soy español
pero vivo en República Checa. Eso significa
que muchas veces vuelo a Madrid para ver a
mis amigos y a mi familia. Durante años,
los vuelos Praga-Madrid costaban alrededor
de 200-250 €. Pero este año, Ryanair ha
llegado a la ciudad. Y ha ofrecido vuelos
Praga-Madrid por precios tan bajos como 75€
¿Qué han hecho las demás aerolíneas que
volaban a España? Pues no les ha quedado
otro remedio que bajar sus precios. Era eso
o desaparecer. Lo mismo ha ocurrido en toda
Europa. Allí donde Ryanair ofrece sus vuelos
a precios de saldo, el resto de compañías
tienen que bajar sus tarifas también. Eso
significa menos beneficios o incluso la bancarrota.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2000,
British Airways llegó a transportar a más
de 46 millones de pasajeros. 8 años más
tarde, a duras penas llegaban a los 33 millones.
Y, lógicamente, esas grandes aerolíneas
como Lufthansa, British Airways o Iberia,
se han gastado auténticas fortunas en comprar
publicidad en los medios de comunicación.
Con eso, se ganaban el cariño de los periodistas.
Y una campaña de desprestigio hacia Ryanair,
que apenas compra espacios publicitarios.
Sin embargo, pese a la mala prensa, pocas
empresas han cambiado tanto una industria
entera como Ryanair ¡Y no sólo hablamos
de Europa! La influencia de Ryanair se nota
en prácticamente todo el mundo… menos en
Latinoamérica.
Así que la primera pregunta que nos tenemos
que hacer es ¿Cómo ha cambiado el mundo
Ryanair? ¿Por qué decimos que Latinoamérica
necesita una empresa como esta? Y lo que es
más importante ¿Por qué Ryanair ofrece
precios tan bajos? Hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas… pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
¿POR QUÉ RYANAIR ES TAN BARATO?
En los años 80, un vuelo Madrid-Londres valía
unas 100.000 pesetas, que es el equivalente
a 600 euros.
En aquella época, eso era el
sueldo de un mes para un español medio. Todo
el mundo daba por sentado que volar era un
lujo. Los aviones son caros. No hay nada que
se pueda hacer. Sin embargo… mis queridos
amigos de VisualPolitik, las razones por las
cuales los vuelos eran tan caros tenían poco
que ver con la tecnología y mucho con la
política. Tal cual como lo oís.
Por aquellos años, las rutas aéreas dependían
de acuerdos entre gobiernos. Por ejemplo,
el gobierno Francés y el Estadounidense tenían
un acuerdo según el cual, sólo las aerolíneas
francesas o las estadounidenses podían volar
entre París y Nueva York. Y lo mismo ocurría
con el resto de países. Esto significa que
las aerolíneas tenían un monopolio sobre
los vuelos que operaban… Así que ¿Para
qué iban a competir en ofrecer precios bajos
si podían facturar auténticas fortunas cobrando
600 euros por un vuelo?
Así que, por aquel entonces, sólo los británicos
y los irlandeses podían disfrutar de esos
vuelos baratos que ofrecía Ryanair. Sin embargo,
en abril de 1997, las cosas cambiaron para
siempre.
“A partir de este mes, cualquier aerolínea
técnicamente cualificada en Europea podrá
ofrecer servicios en todos los países”
De repente, todas las aerolíneas europeas
podían competir entre ellas. Pero como no
estaban acostumbradas a tener que ofrecer
mejores servicios, se dedicaron a invertir
en publicidad y lujos; mejores comidas, asientos
más cómodos o incluso regalos corporativos
para los pasajeros. Ryanair, sacó nuevos
vuelos con una estrategia totalmente distinta.
“Las otras aerolíneas se preguntan cómo
pueden subir sus tarifas. Nosotros nos preguntamos
cómo podíamos eliminarlas” –Michael
O´Leary
Decir algo así en el año 1997 era una auténtica
locura. Por supuesto que ya existían otras
aerolíneas de bajo coste. Pero Ryanair quería
ir mucho más allá. Y por eso, empezaron
a buscar todo tipo de estrategias para reducir
sus costes al mínimo.
Por ejemplo, el coste
de aterrizar o despegar un avión depende,
en buena medida, de las tasas que cobran los
aeropuertos. Por ejemplo, aterrizar en el
aeropuerto de Bruselas es muy caro. Sin embargo,
60 kilómetros al sur de Bruselas hay otro
aeropuerto, el de Charleroi, con unas tarifas
mucho más baratas. Sólo por el hecho de
usar este aeropuerto, Ryanair se ahorra una
auténtica fortuna.
Otra medida de ahorro es utilizar el mismo
modelo de avión para todas las rutas, el
BOEING 737.
Otras compañías como LUFTHANSA
trabajan con hasta 14 tipos de avión distintos.
Eso significa que necesitan 14 técnicos de
mantenimiento especializados en cada uno de
los modelos. Ryanair sólo necesita unos pocos
técnicos para reparar toda su flota. Y por
eso, mientras Lufthansa necesita varias horas
de descanso entre un vuelo y el siguiente,
Ryanair puede hacer sus inspecciones de mantimiento
en la mitad de tiempo.
Por supuesto, a todo eso hay que sumarle todos
los extras que se ahorran durante los vuelos.
¿Quieres comida en el avión? la tienes que
pagar a parte. ¿Quieres llevar varias maletas?
las tienes que pagar a parte. Si quieres elegir
tu asiento, lo tienes que pagar a parte.
Cada año, Ryanair descubre nuevos detalles
con los que ahorrar costes. Por ejemplo, desde
hace unos años, la parte trasera de los asientos
se alquila como espacio publicitario.
Pero, sin duda alguna, el punto de inflexión
llegó en el año 2000. En ese momento es
cuando Michael O´Leary tomó la decisión
crucial que cambiaría la industria para siempre.
“Que les *** a las agencias de viajes.
Habría que agarrar a esos mamones y dispararles…
¿Qué han hecho por los pasajeros durante tantos años?
Efectivamente, en el año 2000, Ryanair fue
la primera empresa en crear una página web
desde la que se podían comprar los billetes.
Hasta entonces, era prácticamente imposible
comprar un billete de avión a no ser que
vivieras cerca del aeropuerto. Así que los
agentes de viajes eran un intermediario imprescindible.
Y, lógicamente, cobraban comisiones de hasta
el 30%. Pero, de repente, los pasajeros podían
entrar en una página web, buscar el vuelo
más barato y comprarlo. Todo esto que ahora
nos parece completamente normal, fue una auténtica
revolución. Y la bancarrota de muchas agencias
de viajes, que ya no tenían nada que ofrecer
a sus clientes.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2010,
Ryanair era capaz de ofrecer billetes por
una media de 32 €. Fijaros en la diferencia
con los 600 € de los que hablábamos antes.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué los vuelos baratos
son tan revolucionarios? Pensadlo bien, desde
que Ryanair se expandió por Europa, el número
de pasajeros se ha multiplicado por 3 en poco
más de 10 años. Prestar atención a la gráfica
porque no sólo hablamos de turistas. Gracias
a tener vuelos baratos, los programas de intercambio
de estudiantes se han multiplicado por 5 desde
el año 2007. De hecho, seguro que muchos
de los que veáis este vídeo desde España
habréis hecho alguna beca Erasmus. Lo mismo
ocurre con la mobilidad laboral, que se ha
triplicado en la última década. Gracias
a los vuelos baratos, yo puedo visitar a mis
amigos en Valladolid tantas veces como quiera.
Y todo eso por no hablar de la cantidad de
pequeños negocios que han sido posibles gracias
a que ahora, hasta el autónomo más humilde
puede buscar clientes en otros países.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque hay otro
detalle que tenemos que mirar en la gráfica!
Si os fijáis, los vuelos en Europa han crecido
una barbaridad. Sin embargo, en Latinoamérica
no ocurre lo mismo ¿Qué está pasando en
el resto del mundo? ¿Podemos hablar de un
efecto Ryanair a nivel mundial? ¿O es algo
endémico de Europa? ¡Vamos a verlo!
EL EFECTO RYANAIR
¡Ya sé lo que estáis pensando! Ryanair
sólo opera en el Europa ¿Cómo es posible
que hayan tenido semejante influencia en todo
el mundo? Pues… juzgar vosotros mismos.
AirASIA era una aerolínea del gobierno de
Malasia. A principios de los años 2000, estaba
apunto de arruinarse. Pero en el año 2001,
el empresario Malayo TONY FERNANDES la compró
a precio de saldo y decidió imitar este “efecto
Ryanair” que ya empezaba a funcionar en
Europa. Bajo el eslogan de “AHORA TODO EL
MUNDO PODRÁ VOLAR”, empezó a ofrecer los
primeros vuelos low cost en Asia. De repente,
volar desde Kuala Lumpur hasta Macao costaba
menos de 90 dólares.
Y, al igual que ocurrió en Europa, en Asia
han surgido montones de aerolíneas de bajo
coste. Desde LION AIR, en Indonesia hasta
CEBU PACIFIC en Filipinas. Para que os hagáis
una idea, en un país tan pobre y a la vez
tan grande como la INDIA, se han triplicado el
número de vuelos comerciales en sólo 10 años.
Sin embargo, Latinoamérica es una historia
totalmente distinta. Por ejemplo, un vuelo
barato entre Bogotá y Ciudad de México nos
costaría alrededor de 460 dólares.
Comparadlo
con los 86 dólares que pagamos por ir desde
Kuala Lumpur hasta Taipei. Y por si lo queréis
comprobar, las distancias son prácticamente
las mismas.
Un vuelo de 3 horas entre Lima y La Paz nos
sale por casi 600 dólares. En otras palabras…
en Latinoamérica todavía necesitan ahorrar
más del sueldo de un mes para poder hacer
un viaje en avión.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué es tan caro
volar en Latinoamérica? ¿Por qué no hay
ninguna empresa estilo Ryanair que haya revolucionado
los viajes en avión?
La respuesta está nuevamente
en la política. Tal y como funciona la legislación
en los distintos gobiernos latinoamericanos
es prácticamente imposible que surja un Ryanair.
Para que os hagáis una idea, si una empresa
quiere operar en Brasil, necesita que, al
menos el 20% de la propiedad esté en manos
de una compañía brasileña. Y hasta hace
2 años, el porcentaje era aún más alto.
Ahí tenemos el caso de AVIANCA, una aerolínea
colombiana que quería abrir mercados en el
país de la samba y el carnaval. El gobierno
les obligó a crear una empresa nueva, AVIANCA
BRASIL, con  capital brasileño.
Y por eso, AVIANCA y AVIANCA BRASIL son dos
empresas totalmente distintas aunque pertenezcan
al mismo grupo. Pero Brasil no es el único
país que intenta proteger sus aerolíneas.
Hasta el año 2016, los argentinos que quisieran
volar tenían que elegir entre dos aerolíneas,  o bien Argentina Latam, que era privada, o bien
AEROLÍNEAS ARGENTINAS, propiedad del Gobierno, y Argentina
Durante décadas, la administración
de Kirchner se encargó de que ninguna aerolínea
extranjera pudiera competir con sus niñas
bonitas.
Y… lo mismo ocurre con los aeropuertos ¿Recordáis
que os decía que Ryanair podía recortar
gastos gracias a despegar en aeropuertos baratos?
Eso es posible porque en Europa, 1 de cada
4 aeropuertos está gestionado por consorcios
entre los distintos gobiernos y empresas privadas.
Gracias a esto, los aeropuertos tienen que
competir entre ellos por ofrecer tasas más
baratas y mejores servicios. No es casualidad
que estos aeropuertos público-privados gestionan
la mitad del tráfico aéreo europeo.
Pues bien, en Latinoamérica, casi todos los
aeropuertos están gestionados, íntegramente,
por los gobiernos nacionales. Si no hay competencia,
tampoco hay interés por reducir las tasas
aeroportuarias.
En otras palabras, que parece complicado que
se pueda replicar el efecto Ryanair en esta región
¿Cuál es la consecuencia de esto? Pues que
aunque muchos países de Latinoamérica hayan
crecido económicamente, y cada vez más gente
esté saliendo de la pobreza, volar sigue
siendo un privilegio para las clases altas.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Creéis que habría
una mayor integración entre los países latinamericanos
si se liberalizara el espacio aéreo? ¿Os
gustaría tener un Ryanair en vuestro país?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si queréis descubrir cómo
IRLANDA salió de la pobreza y se convirtió
en la potencia que es hoy en día, podéis
hacer click en este otro vídeo.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que, suscribíos
a este canal para no perdeos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.